this video is sponsored by Squarespace
so you think you know strength you think
you know everything there is to know
about moving weight and building muscle
H what have I told you that's only
scratching the surface of what your body
is capable of what if I told you there's
a whole world out there of different
training what if I told you that it's
not just about moving the weight but
controlling the
weight mastering the
weight now you have two choices you can
choose to take the green pill and return
to the weights room as though nothing
had ever happened or you can take the
squishy egg and find out just how deep
this Rabbit Hole
goes Wise
Choice muscle strength without control
lacks finesse and
utility it's all good and well being
able to lift something off the ground in
one explosive movement but can you hold
it at arms length can you lift it slowly
I always loved scenes in movies and TV
shows like Dragon Ball where the
characters catch a punch just inches
from their face and hold it there
strength at awkward angles on demand and
I've always been Amazed by The
Incredible strength and control
exhibited by hand balancers and
calisthenics athletes to raise
gracefully into a handstand and then
demonstrate complete body control in
that inverted position you don't get
this kind of strength through heavy
lifting alone you get it through heavy
lifting with control that means training
the slow twitch fibers and this
technique might also be the key to
unlocking bigger lifts in the gym and
even increasing your running
speed so you think you know about
increasing strength and
muscle most weightlifting and strength
training focus on lifting weights with
explosive force this trains the larger
motor units and the fast twitch muscle
fibers for reference motor units are
groups of muscle fibers that always fire
together and these are organized by type
fast twitch muscle fibers are the fibers
that produce the most Force but have the
lowest endurance this is typically what
we want to focus on if we're building
power training big motor units that
contain lots of fast twitch muscle
fibers results in Greater strength gains
on those lifts and leads to bigger
muscles what's not to
like well one issue with this kind of
training is the strength curve when you
perform an explosive bench press for
example you actually only really apply
maximum effort at one point during the
movement this is less true if you're
grinding out the movement but even then
you'll find that certain portions of the
range of motion the ROM involve lower
effort of course these will be weaker
and as such you will always need to
generate momentum to move heavy weights
past this point and if for whatever
reason you get caught in that position
you won't be able to exert as much
strength
you can lift the weight but you're not
its Master you can't manipulate the
weight you can't control it but what's
going on here I won't go into great
detail but seeing as we know that motor
units fire on an All or Nothing basis
they can't half fire you might there
wonder how training can lead to this
angle
specificity there are a few answers that
I might go into in future but largely it
comes down to muscle architecture that
is to say it comes down to the structure
of the muscle and the way the fibers are
physically arranged for example
something called the penti angle refers
to the angle of fibers in relation to
the tendon this is something you don't
hear about much in Fitness content but
it's really interesting angling the
fibers more allows thicker fibers to be
packed into tighter
spaces likewise the length of fibers can
also vary and I made a video on this
very recently this is due to an increase
in sarir in series in other words we're
adding on to the ends of the fibers
longer fibers are better at producing
range of motion and velocity you can
encourage an increase in muscle fiber
length using eccentric training watch
that video for more in that video I also
mentioned how this could alter the
optimum length of the muscle that means
changing the length at which the muscle
is capable of producing the most Force
so you have a different level of
available strength depending of course
on your starting position if you're arm
is fully locked out for example you'll
likely be able to produce less force in
a curl than if it's already partially
bent this can actually vary from muscle
fiber to muscle fiber though meaning
that you might have more fibers within a
single muscle that favor a certain
length or you might have a more even
distribution across the full range of
motion you then need to think about the
type of fiber the nervous system also
plays a role the way in which you
control the muscles not only can you
improve your intramuscular coord
coordination in order to exert the
precise type of force you need for the
task at hand meaning you call to action
precisely the motor units and muscle
fibers within the muscle that you need
but you can also improve your
intermuscular coordination intermuscular
coordination refers to the way that the
muscles work together to get a job done
because very few activities involve just
one muscle so for example if you're weak
at the end range of a movement it might
actually be because your own muscles are
resisting the action at that position if
you lack strength at the top of a
shoulder press for example it might be
because your lats and pecs are trying to
pull your arms back down to overcome
this you need practice and this way you
learn reciprocal inhibition this happens
unconsciously that means that the
antagonistic muscles the muscles that
work in opposition to the movement need
to relax while the working muscles
contract maximally and this only comes
with
practice but the real key to this kind
of controlled power is to train the slow
twitch muscle fibers and the smaller
motor units that contain them so type
one muscle fiber is slow twitch that
means it has better endurance but
produces less power typically we think
of less power as being a bad thing when
it comes to strength training but in
fact it's crucial for exerting control
over resistance imagine that you're
trying to push a very heavy box remember
motor units cont tract in a single All
or Nothing response so if you utilize
your strongest motor units in one big
explosive force then you are going to
push that box forwards with acceleration
this is good if you want to quickly move
the box from point A to point
B what if you need to push that heavy
box precisely what if you need to push
it perfectly onto an outline for
example well now you need to not use the
very biggest and fastest motor units
because you otherwise slide it too far
instead you need to use just the right
combination of motor units to move the
Box by the smallest increments and this
is intramuscular coordination
it's about having a refined signal to
the muscles a little finesse about
choosing precisely how much force you
want to employ this is how you can
engage in any fine movement when
handwriting for example you use tiny
amounts of force by recruiting only the
smallest motor units in the hands and
forearms this in turn allows you to make
small controlled movements if you use a
slightly bigger motor unit the sudden
jolt of force would result in a chaotic
and uncontrolled writing style and we
see this when we try and write with our
non-dominant hands this is also how for
example I might slowly lift a weight
through its full range of motion it's
also how I can slowly lower myself from
a handstand push-up and it's how my body
is able to make tiny adjustments in my
forearms and shoulders to ensure I stay
balanced in a handstand keep in mind I'm
not great at this I'm just showing my
examples I've been working on it a lot
lately though but if you don't train
slow twitch fiber you won't have this
control and finesse you will have blunt
force but you won't be able to balance
or control the resistance to command the
weight so what do you do about it well
the answer is simple train the movements
more slowly this will likely involve
using slightly lighter weights at first
and then building back up to bigger
numbers doing this Alters the signal you
sent to the muscles so that you aren't
recruiting all of the very largest motor
units and are now reliant on those
smaller and slower ones owing to
something called henan size principle we
actually always use our smaller motor
units in conjunction with the larger
ones that's because the body recruits
motor units in ascending size order and
strength well think of it this way the
smaller units have a lower signal
threshold that needs to be crossed in
order for them to fire as compared to
the larger ones all we control is the
size of the signal being sent and thus
any signal strong enough to recruit the
larger motor units will also recruit the
smaller ones on by definition so surely
you can just train heavy and fast and
know that all the motor units big and
small are being trained the problem is
these smaller units fatigue much more
slowly than the bigger ones and that
means that if the weight is too heavy
you'll reach failure before you've
adequately stimulated the smaller slower
fibers and you won't be able to go slow
enough to not use those big strong
ones so slow that bad boy right down and
challenge yourself to maintain positions
in order to effectively train the
smaller motor units likewise try awkward
positions and training that involves a
little more balance this will teach you
to make fine adjustments to your
position using smaller motor units and
supporting muscle groups you will learn
to command your body and the weight with
finesse you might be worrying now about
converting all of your strength into
slow endurance but that's not really an
issue first of all I'm not suggesting
that you only use this kind of training
I'm suggesting that you combine it with
other more explosive movements I'm
suggesting that we combine power and
explosiveness with control finesse and
precision at the same time it's not that
easy to convert type 2 fiber into type 1
fiber this only happens to a small
degree although there's some genetic
variability there just don't worry about
it it's perfectly possible to have
finesse and control and balance as well
as pure brute strength and explosiveness
and this is why I love varying Tempo in
my workouts why I love performing slow
one-handed push-ups and another reason I
love hand balancing it's an entirely
different expression of strength and
there are actually many more good
reasons to go slow too for example maybe
you caught earlier that I said slow
twitch muscle fibers and smaller motor
units are always recruited that means
that even the most explosive activities
in the world like sprinting actually
also involve the slow twitched muscle
fibers alongside the fast twitch and
that means that training them can
contribute to more Speed and Performance
not to mention giving you more control
and balance similarly slow twitch muscle
fibers can grow and get thicker just
like fast twitch muscle fibers they're
not as thick and they're not as big but
because there's more of them they take
up roughly the same amount of volume so
if you hit a plateau when it comes to
building muscle slowing down can help
you to tap into additional muscle growth
by stressing those slower motor units
and muscle fibers the list goes on stop
ego lifting and learn to command the
weight thanks for watching
and bye for now this video is sponsored
by Squarespace Squarespace is a website
building platform that lets users create
modern attractive websites in a matter
of minutes and I'm not exaggerating
creating a website on Squarespace is as
simple as choosing a template you like
the looks of and then customizing it
with an intuitive drag and drop system
there's literally nothing stopping you
from building your own site whether it's
to promote a business to express
yourself or just to take on a new
creative challenge you'll now be able to
benefit from a slew of features from
Advanced formatting tools for creating
beautiful blog posts to fully integrated
social media features like Easy Share
buttons and feeds published straight to
your site to members only gated content
appointment scheduling and comprehensive
e-commerce tools for Revenue generation
there's even a fully featured commenting
system with threaded comments replies
and likes not to mention analytics and
SEO tools the list goes on from there
you can choose from the wide selection
of plugins to extend your site's
capabilities and build it out as you
need this way you can access things like
Inventory management global Shipping and
more if you want to learn more head over
to squarespace.com and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com bioner
for 10% off the domain or website thanks
again to Squarespace for sponsoring this
video thanks to you guys for watching
and bye for now